ayew la fiche est explicite cette
artiste comme une vingtaine d'autres ce
soir la recherche un mécène ou un parent
l'arche des arts et la société en
pulsions met en relation monde culturel
et monde économique pour créer des
partenariats et du mécénat en réalité
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle le mécénat
est dans les mains des collectivités
locales de l'état ou des très grandes
entreprises et nous avons pensé dans
large des arts avec nos partenaires
qu'il était utile sinon indispensable de
sensibiliser les petites et moyennes
entreprises à financer le monde de l'art
et de la culture
une quarantaine d'artistes une
soixantaine d'entreprises la plupart
franciliens ont été sollicités pour
cette soirée
cette pme et l'on courtois s'est lancé
il y a un nom en parrainant une artiste
guillon courtoise l'art dans
l'entreprise ça apporte une autre
dimension à l'entreprise ça apporte une
découverte pour nos collaborateurs
également pour l'artiste ça lui amène
une autre dimension qui à dimension de
l'entreprise avec une autre réalité et
nous avec notre artiste ya un parallèle
entre ces oeuvres et notre milieu
industriel dans lequel nous travaillons
ça prenait vraiment tout son sens en
fait pour moi puisque
je suis vraiment vraiment
mis dans l'entreprise je suis bien
intercalé dans l'entreprise j'ai mes
tableaux ont été exposés sur des
palettes
mais comme je travaille essentiellement
sur l'industriel ça prenait vraiment
tout son sens une nouvelle soirée de
rencontre est prévue pour l'année
prochaine impulsion et l'arche des arts
ouvrent aussi leurs actions en direction
d'orléans